hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer ich habe vor einigen
tagen dieses video hier auf youtube
entdeckt von crafter ist ein vollidiot
bevor ich mir das video angeschaut habe
wenn ich zunächst auf den kanal des
urhebers gegangen und habe mir dort
seine kanal beschreibung angeschaut und
darin steht was ich mache unterhaltung
bruder dann bin ich aber zurück zum
video gegangen und habe dort gesehen
dass das video tatsächlich 4238 aufrufe
hat und er doch selbst im titel
geschrieben hashtag 1 trends und hashtag
bester youtube und dann habe ich mir
tatsächlich auch mal die bewertungen des
videos angeschaut und siehe da das video
fand nicht so viele leute cool aber das
ist natürlich nur das subjektive
einschätzung ich würde allerdings sagen
wir werfen noch kurz einen blick in die
kommentare unter dem video und dann
schauen wir uns endlich dieses
meisterwerk an junge was mit dir falsch
ein bizeps nichts außer speckrollen
vollidiot der titel des falsch das heißt
rauchverbot ist ein vollidiot ich habe
nur noch lust die eine in die fresse zu
geben guten du solltest du dringend
einen psychologen holen nun halt noch
1000 weitere kommentare die irgendwie
alle gegen ihn sind
vielleicht ist die ganze nicht
unberechtigt und daher würde ich sagen
schauen wir uns jetzt mal die erste
szene des videos zusammen kameraleute
kamera angeht alles funktioniert alles
ewig konnte nicht weder sehen noch hören
funktioniert alles normalerweise starte
man sowas doch auch raus oder also wenn
ich zu beginn eine aufnahme klatsche und
die tonspuren synchronisiere
wahrscheinlich dass ja auch raus aber
gut
wir schauen mal was genau leute ich bin
wieder back in business schaut euch
diesen bizeps an
schauen wir uns noch mal zusammen seinen
bizeps an ich werde immer breiter
jede meine reaktionen in diesem video
wird vermutlich einfach nur so seien
aber kaum weiter geht's heute geht es
diesmal um luca ich habe eindeutig habe
ich habe leute ich habe hier gebracht
genau also genauso sehe ich das nämlich
auch er hat was tägliches gemacht leute
was ich lege es okay was er hat nämlich
was hat er gemacht freunde sich auch
jetzt wissen er hat seine reichweite
wollte er nutzen er wollte so einen klub
in so einem club ist da reingegangen
gott ok darum geht die story ist schon
ein paar monate her aber gut an und ich
es nicht mitbekommen haben wir hier noch
mal kurz die ganz kurze grobe
zusammenfassung der situation
wir hatten eine kooperation mit einem
düsseldorfer diskotheken club bar
whatever i hat eine kooperation
ausgearbeitet und an dem an bord das
ganze stattfinden sollte hatten manager
mir die nummer geschickt von dem
türsteher des clubs und unsere
unterhaltung fand ich ein bisschen
komisch und er hat mich dann abgewiesen
und meinte sie brauchen meine provo
nicht und ich habe darauf jetzt nicht
reagiert habe dann aber drei tage später
ein dummes lang jetzt video dazu gemacht
und das war blöd und ich hab aus meinem
fehler gelernt und ich hätte das einfach
für mich behalten müssen und hätte
darüber stehen müssen aber
ja ich bin einfach auch menschen nicht
mehr fehler und das war halt ein fehler
und ich hab mich einfach abgefuckt dass
diese kooperation nicht zustande kamen
an der weser deswegen auch düsseldorf
gefahren sind aber darum geht es auf
jeden fall in dem video hier ich bin
gespannt was er jetzt dazu sagt das geht
auf jeden fall nicht mein gott es geht
nicht nein du musst für den klub zahlen
sagt okay ist ein fakt ich muss für den
klub bezahlen
ja ich kaufe dann den club der einzige
der rein darf bin ich ja ich
[Musik]
du bist ja natürlich komme ich da easy
rhein ganz klar ich kann meine kontakte
spielen lassen und dann komme ich ihr
sie in den clubräumen alter easy easy
lisicki sie als easy easy peasy ach so
dass also deine taktik aber jetzt
bedankt sich der user namens raucher
hier nochmal bei seiner community
aber seht einfach selbst also ich würde
mich auch noch mag es schon mal gedanken
ja für den ganzen super hat er richtig
support gegeben so möchte ich euren
support haben
weißt du was ich so bin ich jetzt auch
ist leicht mich weil dislike sind likes
ja jetzt habe ich geschenkt
danke dir ich dachte mein leben lang das
like sind und des leiters des langsam
ein wimpel auf kopf gestellt seit ihr
seid ihr seid kellermann und ihr seid
meine freunde jetzt verabschiedete er
sich allerdings von seinen freunden hat
er ein alter bleibt dreckig alles klar
ich muss dann halt nicht mehr und jetzt
kommt auch schon zum ende seines
telematischen meisterwerks von video
hier
das lasse ich jetzt einfach mal
ungeschnitten einfach hier laufen also
genießt die letzten sekunden des videos
von raucher kein kies alter ihr könnt
jetzt abschalten
es bietet nichts mehr passieren sagt
okay aus alter zeit
du kriegst von mir auf jeden fall einer
bodega
er stellte mich dass heute wieder jetzt
endlich auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ich habe dieses video die
letzten tage einfach empfohlen bekommen
hat mir dabei gedacht hey das müssen wir
uns eigentlich zusammen in dem video
anschauen wunder hoffe dass ich meine
reaktion auf das video von rauchen
gefallen hatte ich glaube dass von ihm
ist alles nur ironisch gemeint
ich glaube der meint das alles nicht
ernst und das ist alles nur so spaß
unterhaltungs mäßig also bitte hättet
ihnen nicht allzu deutlich würde mich
auf jeden fall freuen wenn die unter
diesem video hier einen daumen hoch
geben könnte und meinen kanal abonnieren
würdet denn wenn ihr noch kein teil
lucio seid dann verpasst habe ich keine
videos mehr und das ist ganz alter
wahnsinn
[Musik]